colt's offensive coordinator nick
ciriani talked to reporters yesterday
virtually and spoke about the signing of
philip rivers
potential hall of fame quarterback by
the indianapolis colts the big part of
phillip being here is anthony costanzo
quentin nelson ryan kelly braden smith
mark lewinsky those guys are stunned
that's something that he just kept
mentioning after we signed him of how
valuable those guys were to him so
here's the question
who gets the bigger upgrade between
philip rivers and tom brady rivers with
the offensive line or brady with the
enhanced weapons of mike evans and chris
godwin and oj howard and cameron braden
and oh by the way rob gronkowski who's
got the bigger upgrade between the two
chris
you know i i guess at first look if i
was a quarterback i would be more
excited about what you see in tampa i
would i would be going oh my gosh you
know mike evans and chris godwin and
this offense and you know of course the
addition of grump
but i think if you really let me sit
there and think about it and then went
oh okay
all right let me measure this okay yeah
they have that but the offensive line is
really below average in nfl standards
and then okay the colts have some good
weapons maybe not as good as the tampa
bay buccaneers but good but then have a
great o line i'd rather probably be in
phillip rivers situation i i would you
know one i just think you know they take
a little pressure off you with
protecting you of course but also take
pressure off of you because of the run
game and that's where the colts can be
special that way let alone i think they
got some young talent kind of kind of
coming up the the ranks at the receiver
position that can make them dangerous
that's a close one but i think all in
all hey games are one up front and i'd
rather be philip rivers in his scenario
i agree with you especially as you are
older and you need to have that blocking
and we've seen time and again the way
you derail tom brady pressure right up
the middle that offensive line in tampa
bay not as good as the offensive line of
the indianapolis colts and look there
there was suggestions that brady was
interested in the cults the cults didn't
reciprocate i think at a certain level
the colts were concerned about another
josh mcdaniels scenario where
you you flirt with tom brady you work
something out with tom brady there's
winking there's nodding there's a verbal
understanding and the next thing you
know
tom brady stays with the patriots i mean
they're not gonna put their hand on that
hot stove again chris i really do think
that was a factor because between the
two guys
rivers brady both making 25 million this
year it's a no-brainer brady's the guy
you want
definitely there there's no doubt about
that but i don't think it's like buy as
a buy a long shot i don't you know i get
i think this is where it's going to
really help fill the rivers out you know
again the the the chargers offensive
line especially when it comes to pass
protect he's been one of the worst in
football the last few years so i think
if we're going to give philip rivers
like some sort of break as far as his
play is concerned
man he was under duress a lot he really
was so yeah i mean for older type
quarterbacks
i think you are better served to have
that pass protection and that thing and
that part of it also with the
indianapolis colts of course the
familiarity and just knowing you're
going to have a guy that can come in and
especially in a year like this it's
going to work out where hey philip
rivers knows the system he knows this
offense they're not going to be totally
worried about him like starting from
zero here and trying to catch up and
figure it out and do it all part of zoom
meetings so there's a base knowledge
there that i think gives them a big head
start too
yeah look it's going to be interesting
to see what these two guys do uh
especially if tom brady mike is
repeatedly harassed and hit and knocked
around and philip rivers has a clean
pocket all the time uh there's gonna be
some people who say maybe tom brady uh
should have done a little bit more to
get the colts interested in him chris
well maybe maybe you know here there's a
question i got for you like why why did
either of these teams have to pay either
one of these guys 25 million dollars you
know or drew brees 25 million dollars
they all wanted to play they all wanted
to come back you know i understand like
i know your argument you're going to say
hey it's important
bookie's got to drive the cadillac
that's why i i i guess so but i mean
geez everybody knows that you're the man
already at brady and brees and philip
rivers like i this is to me where just
the quarterback market's going insane i
mean hey i love dak prescott he's about
to be the highest paid quarterback or
highest paid player in the history of
the nfl that doesn't make sense and then
hey we're just going to pay play old
quarterbacks who are desperate to play
and they want to play so badly but hey
here's 25 million dollars i just don't
unders sometimes i just don't understand
what teams are doing i just want to be
like you could have paid him 16 and he
would have played they want to play
there's legacy things and implications
here
especially phillip rivers because i
don't think he's definitely options
right right
it was the cults or nothing or backup
for phillip rivers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports